i hold it my son
for the last time
nick cannon and his family suffer a
tragic loss the 41 year old revealing on
his daytime talk show tuesday that his
five-month-old son zen has died of brain
cancer nick says that zen was suffering
from hydrocephalus a complication of
brain cancer which took a turn for the
worse around thanksgiving and i think it
was called uh if i'm not mistaken but it
was like where it was fluid that was
building up in his head and that was the
cause of his head was starting to get
big
and it and when we found out it was more
of a i called it like a
a malignant tumor in his head
uh and so immediately we had to have
surgeries brain surgery we put a shunt
in his head and we were hoping for the
best but thanksgiving we had a uh
a interesting turn
and
the process sped up
you know and and ultimately if anybody
knows how cancers were it was cancer in
the brain
uh
and the the tumor
began to grow a lot
faster nick also tearfully opened up to
his audience about his final moments
with his son i wanted to make sure that
you know i had allowed the sun to rise
and you know kind of hold my son have it
happen
after the last oh
i holding my son
for the last time
but it was still it was a beautiful
setting zen's mother alyssa scott also
opened up about the loss posting a
series of heartbreaking images and
videos of her newborn son to her
instagram page on his show tuesday nick
thanked alyssa praising her strength i
really have to say zinn's mom alyssa was
alyssa was just like the strongest woman
i've ever seen you know was emotional
when she she needed to be but was always
the best mom and continues to be the
best mom possible nick also addressed
returning to work so quickly after
losing a child calling tuesday's show a
celebration of life for zen i didn't
know how i was going to handle today i
didn't know
how but i i just really wanted
you know the
i wanted to grieve with my family
you know what i mean
a source tells et that nick was
scheduled to have two show tapings on
monday december 6 including a live show
those were both unexpectedly canceled on
sunday and a pre-taped episode was aired
on monday instead
i didn't want to make it about any
pageantry or any of that type of stuff
so i kind of went back and forth for
what i should do but i felt like
you know i was always talking you don't
just go through it you grow through it
you keep pushing you know what i mean
nick is a father to six children and
opened up to e.t in september about how
his kids are his everything you do in
your downtime when you do have some down
time um
kids you know i got a lot of them that's
word on the street cause you got a lot
of kids these days
they get my full attention when i'm not
not working and that's like either work
or playing with my kids you're busy with
them kids right exactly that's what it
is that's that's what life is about
that's why we're on the planet
[Music]